are you looking for the career that
combines creativity Innovation and
growth opportunities will a career in
digital marketing offers an exciting and
rapidly growing field for professionals
looking to make their Mark in the
digital ERA with the Advent of
technology and the proliferation of
online platforms businesses increasingly
rely on digital marketing strategies to
reach their target audience according to
a report by LinkedIn digital marketing
rules were among the top 10 most
in-demand jobs in 2022 in addition the
global digital marketing industry is
expected to reach a staggering 389
billion dollars by 2026 indicating the
immense potential for career growth so
whether it's managing social media
campaign optimizing search engine
rankings or creating compelling content
a career in digital marketing offers
endless opportunities for creativity
Innovation and profession advancement so
jump into this Dynamic field and carve a
successful path in the ever-evolving
world of digital marketing which simply
learns post-graduate program in digital
marketing designed by industry
professionals this comprehensive program
equips you with practical skills and
extensive knowledge to thrive in the
fast-paced digital world from SEO to
social media marketing content creation
to analytics you will master all
essential aspects required to dominate
the digital landscape gain hands-on
experience with industry standard tools
work on real world projects and receive
personalized mentorship throughout your
journey Unleash Your Potential and
elevate your digital marketing skills
enroll today to become a game changer in
the online marketing the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
but don't just take our word for it
listen to what our Learners have to say
about our courses during my graduation
we were taught traditional advertising
but the industry demanded digital skills
so finding a job in the digital
marketing domain was a challenge for me
I thought a certification in digital
marketing would help me get a job and it
did after the course I was hired by
pantalo as a digital media specialist
with a 20 salary hike and now I'm
finally doing what I like
hey I'm Isaiah Moore I live in Arizona
and the United States I did my
graduation in 2020 in strategic
Communications from Northern Arizona
University in 2020 I joined Nova Home
Loans as a trailing documents
coordinator and worked there for almost
a year in fact I worked at various
places as a student but after graduation
I couldn't find a job in my field of
study or anything that aligned with my
interests I gave tons of interviews but
without any luck the reason
I lacked practical skills on top of that
I had no certification in digital
marketing in particular
so last year I decided to upskill myself
with a professional certificate program
in digital marketing offered by simply
learn in collaboration with Purdue
University I think it was a very good
decision I really liked the curriculum
it helped me enhance my Knowledge and
Skills last year itself after the course
I was hired by panalope as a digital
media specialist with a 20 salary height
and this year I was promoted to digital
marketing accounting
I finally found my footing in the
digital marketing domain and I think the
certification had a huge role to play
the certification helped me pursue my
desired career path
I can use my skills and experience to
become a freelance digital marketer one
day upskilling has helped me turn my
dream into a reality so without any
further Ado let's dive into the most 15
in-demand job rules you can consider to
make a successful career in digital
marketing let's start with content
marketing content marketing plays a
crucial role in establishing a strong
online presence let's discuss three key
job roles within content marketing first
up we have a copywriter or a Content
writer he is responsible for creating
engaging and persuasive written content
they craft compelling blog post articles
social media captions website copies and
more now let's talk about the skills
required to excel in this role a
copywriter or content writer should have
excellent writing skills a creative
mindset and an ability to adapt to the
writing style of different platform and
target audience then let's talk about
the experience needed an entry level
positions often require a bachelor's
degree income communication journalism
and the relative field however
experience and a strong portfolio of
writing samples are highly valued in
this field let's talk about the salary a
salary of a copywriter or content
creator varies depending on the factors
such as experience locations and Company
size on an average they can earn around
sixty thousand dollars per year next up
the content manager this role involves
overseeing content creation managing a
team of writers and ensuring the content
aligns with the company's school and
brand identity the skill required to be
a content manager it should have an
excellent organizational and project
management skill they must also process
a deep understanding of content
marketing strategy SEO principle and the
ability to analyze data and metrics as
for the experience content manager often
have several years of experience in
content creation or related fields a
bachelor's degree in marketing
communication or a similar discipline is
typically preferred then we have salary
the salary of a content manager can earn
around eighty thousand dollars per year
depending on their experience and the
organization they work for lastly we
have content strategist this role
involves developing a long-term content
strategy that aligns with the company's
marketing objective content strategist
conduct market research identify target
audience and create a Content creation
and distribution roadmap as for the
skills required content strategies need
the combination analytical and creative
skills they should be proficient in data
analysis have a deep understanding of
SEO and a social media trends and
possess excellent communication skills
content strategies typically have
several years of experience and content
marketing or a relative field a
bachelor's a master's degree in
marketing communication or a similar
discipline is often required a Content
strategist can earn around seventy
thousand dollars per year depending on
their expertise and the organization
that work for now let's check out some
of the intrinsic digital marketing rules
first up we have digital marketing
intern they play a crucial role in
assisting with various digital marketing
campaigns they support the teams in
content creation social media management
data analysis and campaign optimization
digital marketing intern should
understand the marketing principles
social media platforms and analytical
tools strong communication and
organizational skills are also important
this is an entry level position and
while a bachelor's degree in marketing
or related field is appreciated it can
be flexible requirement internship or
previous experience in marketing can be
advantages the salary for a digital
marketing intern varies wildly depending
on the location and the organization
they work for on an average an intern
can earn around forty five thousand
dollars per year then we have digital
marketing manager he is responsible for
developing and executing comprehensive
digital marketing strategies to drive
brand awareness increase online
visibility and generate leads a digital
marketing manager should possess a broad
range of skills including a strong
understanding of various digital
marketing channels data analysis project
management and Leadership skills a
digital marketing manager typically has
several years of experience in digital
marketing often in specialized role such
as social media or content marketing a
bachelor's degree in marketing or a
related field is commonly required the
salary of an digital marketing manager
varies based on experience location and
the size of the company on an average
they can earn around ninety thousand
dollars per year
now let's talk about social media
marketing
you become an essential component of
digital marketing let's talk about four
significant job roles within social
media marketing first up social media
intern they assessed in managing social
media accounts creating and scheduling
content monitoring engagement and
analyzing social media metrics social
media interns should have a solid
understanding of various social media
platforms content creation and basic
data analysis strong communication and
organizational skills are also essential
this is an entry level position and
while a degree in marketing a related
field is beneficial it can be optional
previous experience or internship in
social media management can be
advantageous the salary of social media
in turn varies depending on location and
the organization they work for on an
average an intern can around forty
thousand dollars per year next let's
talk about social media manager they are
responsible for developing and
implementing social media strategies
managing social media campaigns and
engaging with the audience to build
brand loyalty
social media managers can be well versed
in social media platforms content
creation analyticals tools and have
excellent communication and customer
service skills a social media manager
typically have several years of
experience in marketing or related field
a bachelor's degree in marketing
communication or a similar discipline is
often preferred
a social media marketing manager can
earn around sixty thousand dollars
annually depending on their experience
and the organization they work for and
then we have social media specialist
they focus on executing social media
strategies creating engaging content and
managing advertising campaigns it's a
social media specialist should have
strong understanding of social media
platform content creation advertising
techniques and data analysis excellent
communication and creativity is also
crucial social media Specialists
typically have a few years of experience
in social media marketing or a related
field a bachelor's degree in marketing
or a similar discipline is often
preferred the salary of social media
specialist can earn around fifty
thousand dollars per year depending on
their experience and the organization
they work for at last we have the brand
managers they're responsible for
developing an implementing brand
strategies across various marketing
channels including social media they
work closely with the marketing team to
maintain a consistent and brand identity
to drive brand growth brand managers
need a deep understanding of branding
principles marketing strategies consumer
behavior and excellent project
management skills strong communication
and creativity are also vital brand
managers typically have several years of
experience in marketing or a related
field while a bachelor's or a master's
degree in marketing or communication or
a similar discipline is often required
the salary for a brand manager can earn
around hundred thousand dollars annually
depending on their experience and the
organization they work for now let's
explore Dynamic field of email marketing
it is a powerful tool for reaching and
engaging with the target audience let's
discuss the role of email marketing
specialist an email marketing specialist
is responsible for developing and
executing email marketing campaigns
managing subscriber list creating
engaging email content and analyzing
campaign performance an email marketing
specialist should have a solid
understanding of email marketing best
practices email automation platforms
copywriting skills data analysis and
attention to detail and creativity are
also necessary an email marketing
Specialists often have an experience in
marketing or related field focusing on
email marketing a bachelor's degree in
marketing or a similar discipline is
often preferred the salary of an email
marketing specialist can earn around
sixty thousand dollars per year
depending on their experience and the
organization they work for then we have
the Whimsical world of search engine
optimization it is essential for
improving a website visibility in search
engine results let's explore various job
roles within the SEO field let's start
with SEO analyst they are responsible
for conducting keyword research
analyzing website performance and
providing recombination to improve
organic search ranking and SEO analyst
should have a strong understanding of
SEO principle keyword research tools
data analysis and web analytics an SEO
analyst typically have experience in SEO
or relative field a bachelor's degree in
marketing computer science or a similar
discipline is often preferred the salary
for an SEO analyst can earn around 75
000 per year depending on their
experience and the organization they
work for then we have the SEO specialist
they focus on implementing SEO
strategies optimizing website content
and monitoring website performance to
increase organic search traffic an SEO
specialist should possess a deep
understanding of SEO techniques keyword
research content optimization and web
analytics tools an SEO Specialists
typically have few years of experience
in SEO or related field a bachelor's
degree in marketing computer science or
a similar discipline is often preferred
the salary for an SEO specialist can
earn around sixty thousand dollars per
year depending on their experience and
the organization they work for next in
the line are SEO strategist they are
responsible for developing and executing
comprehensive SEO strategies conducting
competitive analysis and working closely
with the content creators and web
developers to optimize websites for
search engines SEO strategies need a
deep understanding of SEO principle
keyword research content optimization
and web analytics an SEO strategist
typically have several years of
experience in SEO or a related field a
bachelor's degree in marketing computer
science are a similar discipline is
often preferred the salary for an SEO
strategist can earn around ninety
thousand dollars per year depending on
their experience and the organization
they work for finally we have the
director of SEO who is responsible for
leading and overseeing an SEO strategy
for an organization they manage a team
of SEO professionals collaborate with
cross-functional teams and ensure the
implementation of effective SEO
practices the director of SEO should
have an extensive knowledge of SEO
principle search engine algorithms web
analytics and Leadership skills
directors of SEO typically have several
years of experience in SEO or related
field including experience in managing
teams a bachelor's or a master's degree
in marketing computer science or a
similar discipline is often required the
salary for a director of SEO can earn
around two hundred thousand dollars per
year depending on the experience and the
organization they work for finally Our
Last Hope is paid marketing also known
as the pay per click PPC advertising it
is a method of driving targeted traffic
to a website through paid advertising
campaigns let's look at the role of PPC
specialist a PPC specialist is
responsible for creating and managing
paid advertising campaigns on platforms
like Google ads and social media
advertising Network they optimize
campaigns monitor performance and ensure
a high return on an ad spend PPC
Specialist or should have a strong
understanding of paid advertising
platforms keyword research ad
copywriting and data analysis PPC
Specialists typically have experience in
digital marketing specifically in
managing PPC campaigns certification in
Google ads or similar platform is often
preferred the salary for PPC specialist
can earn around sixty thousand dollars
per year depending on their XP
experience and the organization they
work for and there you have it we have
explored various job rules within
content marketing digital marketing
social media marketing email marketing
SEO and paid marketing each position has
unique responsibility required skills
experience and salary ranges whether you
are writer analyst strategist or a
manager the digital marketing field
offers diverse and reward career
opportunities but what are the top
hiring companies in the field of digital
marketing here are the companies that
are recognized for their strong digital
presence and offer exciting career
opportunities in various digital
marketing roles first up Microsoft as a
global technology leader Microsoft hires
digital marketing professionals to
manage their online advertising
campaigns content marketing strategies
and search engine optimization efforts
then we have IBM a renowned technology
company that offers digital marketing
roles in social media marketing digital
analytics and marketing automation they
provide innovative solutions to drive
digital growth next up is Salesforce a
leading customer relationship management
platform offering digital marketing
solution they hire Professionals in
rules such as digital marketing
strategist email marketers and social
media specialists after that we have
Oracle a multinational technology
company specializing in cloud-based
software solutions they hire digital
marketing experts to drive their
campaigns optimize their online presence
and generate leads following that we
have cohoila a global Beverage Company
invests heavily on digital marketing
they hire professionals to manage social
media campaigns content creations and
digital advertising strategies finally
we have Nike a renowned Sports April and
footwear company that emphasizes digital
marketing to connect with its customer
they hire digital marketing
professionals to manage their social
media platforms influencer marketing and
online advertising but remember these
are just a few examples of top hiring
companies in the digital marketing
industry there are numerous other
organizations including agencies
startups and e-commerce companies that
offers exciting digital marketing
opportunities a exploring job boards
networking and staying updated with
industry Trends can help you discover
even more companies that align with your
career aspirations and that concludes
our video on careers in digital
marketing where we explored various job
rules responsibilities skills experience
salaries and a glimpse into the some of
the top hiring companies we hope this
has been an informational and valuable
Journey for you if you have any
questions or suggestions for future
videos please leave them in the comment
section below don't forget to like this
video subscribe to our Channel and hit
the notification Bell to stay updated
with the latest content thanks for
watching until then until next time stay
safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here